all right hello chess fans and we're
live all right we greet you from the st.
Louis Chess Club I am Dennis LaRue this
is Mike comer international arbiter my
cupboard international are the white
comer and I am c-class player Dennis
Larew I know whether you're that the Tag
Team Champions only knowing at 28
I am 2018 mid-america mixed doubles
champion this is 1998 Missouri State
scholastic chant alas again at those
Scholastica there and we are here to
play the people so challenge us please
do challenge us yeah I'll be here
reading the YouTube comments
and remember always all challenges have
to be rated all right it doesn't matter
what time control just make sure it's
rated none of this casual chess okay so
far we got a bunch of cowards out there
no one challenged us Mike let's go Stu
scared on the board your first challenge
get the play and I had to warn anybody
playing us today that might be a little
bit more intense oh if only you
mentioned that yes
October 12th that would be national
chest day if you didn't know that
already right at 7 p.m. central will be
having $1,000 National chest day intense
chest invitational and dennis is the
fourth seed in that bracket he'll be
playing one of his great buddies from
blitz bounty Michael Pugachev
Michael and so maybe you can get his
revenge and you say what's intense chess
it's like get with the program already
ok how could they not be like don't even
waste your time I guess if you want to
if you need to yes you start with one
minute in your time bank ok and you get
a 10 second delay so think of that 10
second as your action clock of
shot-clock your move clock but then if
you really need it you got that one
minute time bank but once that minutes
starts go when you'll never get that
time back and it gets really intense
when you're in that bubble so hopefully
you can all join us for that do we have
any challenges yet no do not I'm about
to start a little get the chest going
with a blitz game on I just waiting on
let's not let Salkin 60 become a chess
expert not on our watch
yeah I don't know why I got it yes there
we go there we go all right I am the guy
that been fangled routinely mentions on
his stream I was one of his best pupils
in 2010 so you know I was learning I was
learning but I did break 1,800 on his
watch so I'm thankful for been for that
been fine goals of course in at Atlanta
chess club and scholastic Center of
Atlanta I wonder how he thought of that
name but figured it out what's going on
Bishop g5 pin it and win it that's what
they say that is what they say you did
not announce castle that do not take
that ass you pin your guy to the bishop
so Bishop takes a guy easy I saw I had
this all calculated
no two for one - oh he's just he can't
do it and now we're off to a bad start
[Laughter]
that's why you never pre move in chess
maybe you'll maybe he'll take it maybe
I'll take it it was draw
porcupine sauce is making a lot of sense
Thank You porcupine for having my back
guys
[Laughter]
yeah yeah porcupine sauce he's thinking
yeah how would you know how would you
know unless that's where you're from
maybe right okay enough about that we
could try to get a background check mate
so we always have hope we always have
hope without life there's no hope okay
so without hope there's no life there
however you want to say it there's any
hope okay oh god yeah it's a jerk it's a
trick yeah yeah Jesus I'm hanging stuff
everything is just bad everything's bad
um ooh wouldn't talk to me you know
always play rook the b1 tried but dad
doesn't even work because he's got that
night night there yeah just put my stuff
in the center and let all my pawns fall
right
yeah this is a sad game yeah we do have
a challenge from mr. Maksim so man says
500 casual you've got to be ready to
make it rain make it rain in sir and
then we'll yeah I'll talk to ya later
gotta be rated alert alert
yes I'll Maksim make sure that you do we
have a chess expert rating maximum at
least for the time being yeah yeah we'll
see what I what happens after I'm done
here
we'll see what happens
no we're after a bad start I should just
resign this but I'm in a stubborn mood
yeah yeah yeah my last game I played on
this channel I pressed the resign button
three times it won't let me resign for
the real reason and I came back in one
it was a miracle man well I'm not going
to take that as an inspiration and I'm
just gonna fight fight fight and this
stupid losing pad yeah we got a pickup
we don't even have the pony yeah we
don't have a whole lot of anything to
play for here okay I am gonna resign
this game and they let you let's see
then lecture they let me they knew it
was that bad good game sulk in sixty we
I guess we did
did we make him a next book no not quite
not quite sulking 60 maybe next time
points away okay my points away there is
juice yeah he's a chess expert strong
though so but we're gonna do first come
first serve yeah let's get let's go with
Maksim alright he's not too strong he's
a 2000 week yeah and and by the way it
says you're playing the st. Louis chess
club that means you're playing a
combination of both me and Dennis LaRue
if if I so if I so choose the hell yeah
that's right none of this crying advice
yeah Mike plays or something Mike says a
move yeah
i castled the safety good good good so
far so good what a idea my gonna play
no rush there's no rush you might play
c4 here yeah copied off for you yeah
yeah yeah this is this is the this is
definitely copied chess
you're just playing like the chess
expert huh yeah however you can if you
need to copy his moves copy is me who is
yeah who is winning this position nobody
knows do you know but it's even right
exact Amir and who can be winning who
blinked first to blink first
I knew he was gonna play there it's a
dumb move you're going yeah you're going
you're going places you're going place
that's the claim sir I mean takes on d5
what am i taking with Oh getting that
guy in the same line as you I don't like
it I don't want to either
I mean out of it well I'm just closing
it up um no there's no way to close it
up and just don't get the bishop
involved with this we're going to Queen
d7 we're just making a move we are crazy
7:00 then you play 95 all right you're
too strong for me okay let's see we're
playing here and then okay all right go
back to da da da yeah yeah yeah because
then it weren't send a [ __ ] up to e
whatever whoo we are unstoppable
together Internet we're gonna crush you
guys we don't care what your rating is
Bishop takes you don't care what your
ratings are we're gonna crush you guys
what else is going on into the club Mike
we have our big intense chest oh yeah
yeah that's an October I'll be in
Columbia Missouri of next week for the
2019 Midwest Collegiate Chess
Championships so yeah yeah if you're
from if you go to school in the Midwest
guess what come on down to Columbia
Missouri
October 4th 5th and 6th there's a blitz
match if you just want to play the Blitz
on Thursday night I'll be down there and
then the following week in addition to
the thousand dollar national chess day
Invitational thing we'll have our own
open to the people one thousand dollar
national chess day g30 championship I
might actually be competing in that try
to get that $150 class be top prize
hopefully I'll be the only Class B guy I
almost played oh you almost played
Bishop d5 yeah no this is all wrong this
doesn't feel right but he's just gonna
play knight c6 maybe here yeah you know
I'm thinking Queen d7 2797 check and I'm
fine I don't have the bishop there but
my stuff's in the middle
what you're the only B class and what
well I could be that's what I'm banking
on because we're gonna have a G 30
national chest day open to the
tournament people you know you know four
rounds quick in and out before the big
Invitational Tournament and a lot of
people in Class B and above don't like
to put their rating on the line on such
a quick time control all right so I'm
hoping that you know I'm like one of the
only Class B players around in that
tournament to try to win that $150
first-place prize so so that's the UH
that's the goal sounds like a good goal
good man yeah and I also believe October
12th will be having a scholastic
tournament off-site it's the farewell to
a Tony Chen tournament thing okay all
right Tony ten will be there he won't be
that cheap but he's gonna be yeah it's
gonna be his old family I like it yeah
that's good no toy yeah for those of you
yeah no yeah Tony is is responsible for
holding our scholastic chess chess
events which are which have been really
successful very successful Nicholas
risco claims he might be chess Class B
after this weekend yeah okay all right
those who care yeah he he came in
announcing that he was my flatmate
yesterday Mike because I constantly
taught him and tell him that his rating
my rating floor is his rating ceiling so
for those of you for you aspiring
bullies out there that's a great line to
taunt ear peers into improving with
because now I think he is actually in
the 1,400 bracket and I'm just getting
worse moving up in the world he he would
have if he would have played for prizes
in the in the district championship he
would have received the biggest upset
prize that sounds right but
but then plate surprises don't get the
prize that's the way it works
the Nicholas risco claims these 1508 now
yep so you're 90 some odd points away
good for you Oh on a serious note about
I'm a serious note about actual strong
players congratulations to the club's
very own Caleb oh yeah how could i how
could I forgot huh
yeah he's actually he's on shift right
now he might be watching it watching ion
book okay no way Oh yep so so I
mentioned it last night to him after he
won he is now 2210 national master
congratulations that when I bought my
house okay it is a long story already
I'm sure that's what he really wanted to
hear uh alonga a long-winded story about
how how it's basically all all me
basically they got him in a
nationalistic yeah I can believe Zoey
would it not be you mind coming yeah so
anyway I used to watch the Oscars a
bunch way as a kid and anyway I finally
uh bought a house when I was like
whatever
twenty-eight okay whatever and whenever
I watch the Oscars I was like why are
these like best actors going up there
and like thanking everybody it was like
I did it I'm the best actor thank you
for recognizing me I'm the best that
would have been my Oscar speech I did it
I'm the best you you you I'm better than
you you and you I won't be up there
thank the manager thing doing fancy I
wouldn't do that so I texted the Muppets
so anyway so I finally bought my house I
realized the heirs of my ways oh it
takes a village to get this done anyway
so anyway so I texted Caleb last night
so Caleb's very first tournament chess
tournament was here at the at the Chess
Club anyhow he's playing in one of those
we used to have
beginner tournaments unrated it's like a
goof-off tournament you know so anyway
Caleb's playing in the championship game
to just three and oh and another kids
three no the kids father his opponents
father is watching the game intensely
okay and I'm the director and Caleb's up
mother parent is watching the games from
a distance okay and anyway so
Caleb's opponent makes a move right it
doesn't hit his clock
it's game fifteen no delay no increment
and then his father's like gives them a
little nudge in this like hey hit your
clock so the kid hits a clock and then I
I storm right over there and tell the
parent hey there's the stairs you better
take them you're out of here and then
and there's long story short Caleb wins
and then Caleb's miles comes up to me
after the game and says dude if you want
to kick that guy out if you were to just
let that happen I would have never
brought him back here ever again
so great great directing urine checks
and congratulations to the Caleb Bambi
congratulations to me for however it is
horrible you are keeping his career
going mastery without a doubt slow
that's that's the story of oh my god
whatever no no is the story of how it
might come er made Caleb be a master
okay in a row to win a world
okay good game maksim shoes I thought I
was doing something but I wasn't we have
ten challenges though ten challenges
coming up and we got 50 people watching
Sonic Sasha says what's up y'all
what's up we're just playing some chess
play some rated chess and talking about
the great stuff going on at the st.
Louis chess club okay this guy mister
something yeah let's go mister this is
called mister 97 that's fair alright
what do you got for me buddy
good luck we've driven the highest rated
player out of the room
we did that guy just wants nothing to do
so October is a good good chill month at
the st. Louis chess club kind of it's a
good good way just maybe prepare for a
2020 calendar and that November it's
just one event one event one event right
after another we got the GM I am norm
Thanksgiving open ya Thanksgiving opens
gonna be the biggest only a hundred
fifty slots available for the
Thanksgiving open and if you register
before November third you get a special
discount so make sure to do it and if a
grand master Wei Robson or somebody is
watching our stream today maybe the
Grand Master's have to register by
November 3rd or else you will get money
deducted from your prize winning if you
win so right so make sure to do that
what you got going on give the man
double pawns game yeah nobody's ahead
and development now I'm pretty sure he's
fine here but don't just save that part
he really wants you're pulling yeah I
agree with that well 96 if he takes with
the night and then you play 96 Knight
takes pawn takes and then there you're a
pawn Falls I would maybe just play good
old a6 my eight-point falls - oh yeah
all right you're absolutely right
absolutely right
it's called removing the defender oh no
you should have never taken that Paul
what I should have nobody just Knight to
d7 so we're all agreed 96 is bad ok
we're going with ok ok wait what are you
gonna do he's just gonna play he's gonna
play 95 no matter what King d8 ok and
then I'm gonna get your center pawn ok
you're you did it all for the a pawn
buddy all for the a pawn all right yeah
what all the deep calculators here in
this Studio B are talking about
knight c6 that's what he wanted to play
initially 96 Knight takes Knight pawn
takes he would he would he would just
hate you he he take if you play knight
c6 there he just takes you know it's
over stop living in the past you to stop
living in here they can't even hear you
it's like I'm arguing with a ghost over
here it's like yes a ghost of some other
line yeah yep okay they get on with the
guys Mike here's Mike's genius move yes
boom yep now you've got the a pawn which
was gonna hang anyway but we got your
epon good you'll take it take
hey easy and now let's let's think let's
think let's think I don't need to think
about anything I'm getting the beep on
right now the beep on yeah I'm beat b2
will fall after 93 won't it yeah here no
okay probably against that and I'm also
playing chess with just my knight I
don't need the rest of my pieces he's
gonna humiliate you with rook to d1 cuz
if Knight takes rook d2 and then your
knight has no place to go
yeah but I got so much stuff so excited
together gonna take on b2 then maybe
you've convinced me not to maybe what
what's gonna happen he's gonna play rook
rook d1 on IV - and then Brooke d2 right
yeah and then you got no place to go
okay so if only there was a place to go
a place to go only there was a place to
go okay well maybe we'll just develop
our stuff or you could play Knight c5
and attack the other b-plus yeah but
then again I really just George just
just crush it yet take it take it
tick tick lay here take this guy no no
don't take there to remove the defender
oh my goodness he's too strong yeah and
we got the the lead oh this guy's 1437
what are we so excited about being a
1430 they'll probably give us like a
tenth of a point if we if we win those
of you with the 1400 just don't let like
shame me too much just a little bit a
little bit of shame for being 1,400 but
not a lot yeah especially on a computer
computer yeah so what's this guy even
thinking about maybe you should just
retreat you're not you just tell your
that good job had him on the back and
get that night out of there are you just
okay he did this mission he did this
mission this has a lot of pieces in here
okay but they're not doing anything
they're just joking
not yet if he opens if he opens the D
file then I'm he successfully opens it
then maybe I'm in trouble that's my
think I'm in trouble or singing good old
uh-oh now you listen to what you said
it's fine Oh big deal
good good job for listening and hearing
and using a good idea when you hear it
mister 97 97 the high school thing is we
were probably both in high school I know
I was yeah I was also in high school I
was much younger let's see if we can get
a pass on this is my kind of tests all
right all right said all right take is a
are Y an item six are beep on or
whatever it all it all is super winning
but hearing oh yeah defend their on and
then play this mister its son leave me
name I might have to jump in and take
you on mister it's only a name or
whatever okay yeah yeah we're gonna get
you it's only in the name
okay we're gonna get you dude yeah that
sounds right we should we should get him
yeah let's kill ya let's see you let's
see if you were actually challenged us
raided style - it's only in a name let's
see we have nine challenges up here yeah
what is it the same yeah dude right here
what's your what's your handle mister
it's only in the name too scared to tell
ya tact that defendant night yeah it's
something I will he's gonna play c6 and
I just want to know why are you worried
about it no we shouldn't are you sure
yeah I'm sure
okay let's get him oh he's got checked
to get ride of the pin King d8 and then
what and then I looked let's distract
the rook okay
distract them let's go rook up to F all
the way to the toe all that all the way
you have YouTube handles I'm okay on
whatever you're on whatever okay on
whatever will give you a will give you a
shot at the big time
oh yeah let's go let's go let's go you
in trouble I don't even know how you
want to take just oh just to take this
and take a nap remove take don't let him
get that beep on as a queen okay yes sir
okay its number one point I'm all about
it I'm all about Jack oh yeah you should
have waited for that check we would have
fallen right for it yeah oh that's good
that's good III threatened check are you
I'm with you there I'm with you there
sir pre move it free man free move I'm
so scared over there yeah Oh play rook
back checkmate game over
no he has rook c1 made into Mike Mike
Matt yeah I lose on time it's over good
game whatever let's see what 500
standard 2061 all right okay
trash-talking it moves you up the list
all right no it does no he doesn't even
know how to play the French she doesn't
even know no I smell noob
that's his quote weirdest quoting that's
right because we don't stoop to that
guys no no
got the b6 you're going to see seven
let's not tell mr. om whatever we are
going all right well see sevens might be
okay from what I understand this is yeah
you're supposed to do this and there's
some other element to this that I'm
because I keep trying this against our
co-worker what's that guy's name Kyle
whatever Kyle David Webb okay all right
that's okay I once put his us the effing
Kyle baby that's funny and they should
be permanent you gotta change but they
mail them the card with everything and
made sure you got the premium membership
so it's just like the Kyle g6 so that
was our losing move it's fine you better
get our Bishop back the f8 on the double
get the g7 on the double first of all
the knight is hanging so I got it what I
addressed that wait because it could you
because you everything's removed if
everything's fine
don't worry I love it when people
voluntarily remove the defender it's
like I don't have to do any work justice
thanks make it like one time against mr.
on whatever the whole minute we're doing
great
oh whatever do you remember that song um
whatever I have no idea from 2003
sounds like up but I metal is like glass
of one minute sounds like a song oh
whatever
he's playing us a lot this guy he has a
plus score on the close oh we got we got
a even a buzz in 61 he's trying to
double up he's trying to double up on us
never as long as I play fast
yep just yep just yep yep Bishop g7 just
stick with the plan just stick with the
plan
just stick with the plan all right you
should play nice takes up seven here and
then just pray oh my god Knight takes up
seven you think yeah it's queen yeah
probably
what do you think it one no I'd probably
not what about Knight f8 here yep I love
it yep great love it and the Bishop e6
and then it's like you got nothing kid
it would be as hard it would be harder
to break into Fort Knox yeah I don't
know that know anything about alright
and I know you've never tried to record
show Bishop e6 yep and now he's gonna
play Bishop and I'll play Bishop h8 and
say hahaha yeah love it love it love it
I think yeah I heard the chair move so
Danny hasn't completely fallen asleep in
the next room might actually be watching
the game admit unlikely that he's not
disgusting but if he's watching it
there's still a oh I think we're okay
yeah we're so up on time okay and he's
like trying to do stuff just rook
protect the II what ever oh no oh gosh
he's got so many people on your f7 thing
it's not even funny he is two guys oh
but we have we have one guy that we have
nobody nobody can remember that bishops
move backwards you always need a I
remember I wish I could have like a
cheat sheet during them there would be
number one bishops move backwards but
luckily you were on the ball you knew I
tried yeah don't don't be shy I still
need help oh yeah so no don't say that
that thing's just a big pond he's not a
big pond he's an awesome plan hey super
pond super magical ability to move
backward traveling pine or something
alright so I'm playing
I'm totally playing Knight d7 what do we
think everyone vote against Knight d7
now no because it's your violent
terrorist no Knight h5 is bad because
look look
if you move your knight he's got more
people on f7 understood I agree with you
Maya and I claim to understand I can't
prove that I understand so you have
three defenders and he has three
attackers the map does not add on oh ok
swear oh what's going on he's taken here
because he thinks he's a big shot
no that was big mistake ok Knight takes
that big snake takes this is exciting
it's exciting I know what is doing here
where are you going yeah all right
Knight f6 Knight f6 racer kind of sick
boom alright
I would keep harassing your maybe maybe
ok sure why we're playing this is my
we're playing oh did not want to play
there checkmate no I'm Bishop f1 but
close we're close we're close so close
and now when every moves is a rook no
that just loses a knight straight up yes
sir
because when every moves this rook or
Queens under attack by the bishop that
can move backwards ok so let's just take
his pawn then yeah take his pawn take
his bow at this point let's try to stay
up long time here
inna spawns and it Queen takes pawn is a
reality
Queen takes that center column whatever
nobody oh we went blank
whoa take it take it Ted take a ticket
let's go yeah he can have the b-pawn
it's fine you can have the b-pawn and
now we get your we get with take it
let's take it
prove it prove it oh gosh we got a great
move oh look look all the way to the top
yes sir
you mean we're going to the top I've
never had so much fun playing yes yes
we're trying to even up the score
favorites was up David Chopin he's a
nice guy
Oh weird now the guys having revisionist
history where are you chest worm I saw
you up here Oh chest worm ran away he
was scared okay there's some rate adjust
we need some riches Oh give a Chopin
rate adjust reign of David sorry yeah
get what the program okay so we're doing
this guy this SNP fine all right let's
do it
let's mr. 500 or so right okay so do we
oh okay for the English all right sure
yeah I know all about it I like to play
d5 you play yeah I did the game that won
you the people's champion trophy that's
exactly what against the one time I ever
remember the good old Ben fine goals
really helped me uh helped me win that
in 2017 so actually I gave them a
for his wedding 1916 or 2017 that was
2016 wasn't it no it was 2017 it seems
like a 20 seems like a 2017 type thing
okay so let me see maybe not maybe
there's been three winners since then me
Alexei and then Caleb Gosselin / Sanada
so that would be 20 16 17 18 and now 19
will be a fourth year so okay so 2016 so
anyway long story short Ben Feingold
came back for a minute and gave me some
chest lessons to help me win that and I
gave him a big wedding gift let's just
say double double what it could have
been always double up right
oh we're gonna double up what we're
gonna be done more than ever where we're
good for the day hahaha fair fair okay I
don't even know what I want here this is
a I don't get this
we'll see let's see if he casts will
castle and then be great I'll be great
they are taking challenge is a 5
overrated at leach s yeah
it's true but you can challenge us to
any any time but it seems like we're
playing a lot of five minutes
yeah I don't know why I did that
I should put display 97 but uh we're
gonna do something here what is this guy
doing just let him take the pawn oh now
he's got Knight takes D pawn I don't
care I don't care I don't really care
either
they take D we don't we don't care about
it we better put a knight on c6 or else
we're in a lot of trouble yeah I'm dead
sounds deep what why because of the
bishop yeah cuz Knight takes oh they
takes Queen takes Bishop takes but then
Queen would take I didn't say that yeah
Queen would take on b7 but it's okay
we're we're doing all right all right
Queen takes it this was art this was our
dream yeah but now he's gonna Castle so
we're gonna tell ya either way I'm okay
with my position I'm not gonna cry about
it
what was the name of that thing called I
did invent another chess game I'm not
just the co-creator with Jonathan France
of intense chess but I invented a a game
but I forgot what the name of it is but
it's essentially to reduce the number of
draws in high-level chess if your
opponent castles to one side you are
forbidden from castling from on that
side so you either have to stay in the
middle castle on the other side are
manually castle which takes a while but
I forgot what the name of it was
something kind of cool
but it's just uh I have no idea why you
would you invented another variant yeah
it's okay right it's like if you Castle
if we're playing and you castling
kingside guess what I'm legal for me to
castle on the Kings side no I have the
castle on the other way stay in the
middle are manually Castle which takes
like three or four loops and in your
variant you're obligated to manually
castle no no you don't have to cast okay
but but if my opponent castles King side
I am forbidden to Castle kingside
if my opponent castles Queen side I'm
forbidden I saw I oh so you're always
obligated to do the whole Sicilian
opposite sides castling I'm gonna pawn
storm you right yeah yeah so yeah it
could get way more wins and losses but
obviously maybe you can't even play the
Sicilian is black anymore cuz because my
opponent might be able to castle before
me and then I got a big hole on on the C
file this is okay
why okay oh we have a question why is
Mike not plain weed the title of the
string and just read the title of this
tree knowing that knowing how the chess
pieces moon does not necessarily mean
that you are okay you're interested this
is this called Denis LaRue place the
people what's up I get my time in the
limelight or whatever yeah Mike plays
the people will not be happening this
Friday I will be on the road not mm or
Tunica but somebody will sub in for me
I'll be on the road to Tunica I got I'm
on a free roll it's uh it's a place in
Mississippi I see so if you're in Tunica
stop by and say hi and I'll be at the
sports book cashing in my tickets I'm on
a free roll down there oh my god nicely
follow my mouse slip they're in good
company you and a Benjamin Bach
horrible now sleep oh that hurts that is
painful
mm that is annoying so AAA when you're
though he might take with the bishop and
then you lose the whole Queen I I didn't
pre move its hovering oh just something
I'm sorry - making her do you know this
is a variation of Dani wrenches a trick
whenever whenever you like say you like
we're hovering uh-huh and like oh I
don't even want to move that piece just
place it on top of the king okay cuz you
can't capture the king and his king
obviously in cases Jack yeah all right
yep always under the minute he's under
he's only plus two
he's only plus two either than a
weakling yeah let's go let's go
don't get back whoa checkmated maybe go
for an H five attack sure yeah we want
you to take it let's check we almost
have checkmate here we're so close just
get that oh it took how are you all
right rook up yep work up we're going up
we're making our King a warrior
we're making our king away from them all
right let's get let's get rid of all or
our pawns
oh my god and you just did it you didn't
you didn't put it on the king you put it
on a different square could have gone
there all right 85 85 we get that guy
going hey 585 let's go let's get rid of
all our pawns
oh is that okay are you sure it should
have done checkmate alert announce that
you said checkmate alert Danny I always
have always mentioned checkmate a little
okay supervise our horrible chest
I don't know we were so close to Stanley
what's our what's the tally I've lost
three games we won the big one we want a
big one right we did we did yeah that's
all that's all we really can we did all
right
ac says hi hi AC what's up okay well
that's gonna show pain yeah I'll write
it alright David could get some this is
a Friday action quad participant yes and
yo looking for revenge probably yeah
let's see zero zero no revenge Terry are
you are you are you alive oh it's my
turn
i I can't help myself
alright I really can't I'm sorry oh my
god what are you doing what am i doing
I'm playing I'm shooting the Sicilian
never been given that man of pre pawn
I'm refuting the Sicilian at the but
measly cost of a Klein's David you
really should have read the Langille
variation the Feingold offense for a
mere $25 a dumb book for an hour I can
teach you the Feingold defense yeah this
is not the way to play again yeah okay
spoiler alert you play a six and A six
before move five or something that's
good easy d66
c5 Bishop e7 and then you put Knight d7
you never put your knight on c6 G never
Mario's hat wants to know miles hat
Mario's hat I wonder if they're talking
about our one and only Mario who may or
may not be playing in the intense chest
thousand dollar national chest they
think yeah he's a working man he's a
working man and we got Corey in the
house what's going on Corey if you show
your face your name will get put on the
all right what do you what do you how
can we help you understood who is it a
tag tag yeah yeah yeah all right I like
this one are dark there are Danny do you
want
again and I know okay I've already down
a pawn though I'm gonna pull here down
upon up a minute here you're hitting
some sticks good luck David
you got to play my back in the saddle
back in the saddle again alright Bishop
e5 take it oh you knew I was gonna take
it oh he's got my bishop coming but
that's okay he's playing he's playing
he's a player he do you did not want to
play that check yeah
gave him the big check and I'm never
moving this night I might as well just
pre moved this all right pre move is on
the pre move is on
all right f6
you know if you're been feingold fan you
know you know never play f6 and now we
wouldn't you are you gonna open the F
file for me your king is on the F file
alright play the people it's play the
people
a six not afraid ooh-oh
all right little trick little trick
let's do a little trick even though the
trick pie doesn't even work but you know
what I mean I know well now the trick
works you really shouldn't be playing
just for tricks I mean it's bad so now
I'll play rook to see whatever give the
man a check
ooh hey free pond and the route is on
plus seven so I went from negative one
to up a touchdown who is this guy
I'm up on touched I'm up on touchdown
you you want to see if you can bag for
real I'll buy a touchdown I went for two
the two-point conversion I was negative
one and then oh look at this
checkmate on the board coming up made
into how do you want it alright resigned
and we got some challenges where is that
mr. Alan Jay nobody knows what is rating
is all right Alan Jay we got you we got
you in there
all right and we're on a live show mr.
Allen J a live show you've got about 10
seconds also I'm gonna abort this game
here the five oh you got lucky you got
lucky
b4 c4 c4
what is that about
or do I connect well I could have played
Queen to b6 there but it just wasn't
feeling it I guess
yeah I guess I do not really need a
castle our d5 then Castle d5 then castle
especially with Dennis coming back I
probably shouldn't play to five old game
but um mr. Alan Jays been patiently
waiting in the queue so decided to play
him I'll see what's going on is Dennis
Leroux new no he's that new he's
actually been here quite a while and he
he is me and him are you actually the
assistant managers of the chess club if
you can believe that we're tied for a
fourth in the organisation
he is a c-class player and I think I
almost won something he five or so he
played Eve for and cannot keep up with
this game right now it's going too fast
ooh I could have played something better
but that's okay but it's just do I want
my big you're out of Knights okay you're
out of knights I am the only one with a
knight attacking the b-pawn let's see if
he moves it
who is the manager the manager is none
other than
Jonathan trances the club manager number
three in the organization then Simon is
video guy no other our video consultant
I've been told
c-class player would be the equivalent
of like a 1300 feed a maybe a little
higher something like that
yeah this is not the game of the day
this is not the game see if you see if
you'll take it I'll take double pawns
and try to get something going
my rooks are really bad when you have
like all eight of your pawns it means
your rooks are probably pretty bad all
right now my rook is becoming good and
now I got f5 and all that good stuff
oh it makes it even more trick to the
plate oh he wants my pawn huh no sale
there will be no sale now you always
want to pay attention to what your
opponent's doing in chess there's this
little kid that's really gifted in a
just errand and sometimes he just he's
just doing his own thing and not paying
attention it's just he gotta gotta pay
attention arond gonna be a grandmaster
one day
opposite colored bishops so what's funny
about opposite colored bishops is in the
middle game where it could lead to many
checkmates in the end game draw because
the reason why is because in the middle
game this bishop can't stop what my
bishops doing and vice versa and then
obviously in the endgame we don't have
to go into why it's a draw all right now
this is not fun I guess just trade
queens and call it a day
laughter I play rook takes Queen I'll
offer the draw see why they see if it
takes that
all right no draw okay all right then
then I'm gonna be merciless done but
they call him mr. merciless all right
here we go here we go here we go
Joe if you ever play see three I'm
running it I'm running it up the board
whoo I
oh here we go whoo oh I'm in a pin oh
I'm in a pin hate being in a pin all
right this is gonna be exciting stuff
this is gonna be all right thank you for
not taking the draw you should have
taken the draw when you I could give him
a check or I could take the pass pawn or
I could take with the rook so many
options all right well don't you want to
pass pawn gotta have a passed pawn but
it can't resist a check though right you
can't resist a check check
I saw it live it was like every other
button went away when I offered to draw
am i making that up
my it's called Novato bold so whatever
that means that's what it is
all right well whatever
I got bad news for you buddy your King
can't move did you know that do you know
that that means my king can do whatever
he wants
77 people Oh Oh you put me in this place
how high my king can move damn real
funny
real funny alright f6 never play it but
whatever I'm gonna come in yo big
mistake I made you blink buddy I made
you blink he's a blinker
he's a blinker
oh my gosh hey Caleb
I just got a beat you on time dude I
gave you thousand opportunities to take
a draw and draw I mean I guess the
computer just like whatever draw viewers
count going up since you went solo oh
boy
now Dennis was doing great Oh play like
Fischer play like Fischer oh man I
wanted to play like Fischer but somebody
snuck in right at the buzzer and took
the took the took the challenge play the
people it's probably because it's got
later in the day and more people are off
of work now
white was winning with the H pong but
hook you say so if you say so
white was winning with the age pause oh
because if I'd go Bishop e5 yeah maybe I
don't care it's a draw
it's Bishop of the colors always drop
remember oh no my plan is foiled my plan
is foiled if he takes I take out
whatever my plan is foiled
yeah yeah yeah
and now I can just play Bishop to e3 and
laugh at me now whatever or oh whatever
Denis got the big win today against the
guy that called them out
oh is this is this a joke so I take you
take with check and you yeah fine fine
yeah fine it's like who cares it's like
why you got a discovered check it's like
and you're a chess expert huh oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh the Machuca
rock baby the Machuca danny Machuca
he's our producer he's famous for that
move rook the a7 oh wow think I never
saw it coming Wow right yeah you can't
even move now you can't even move oh
that was your yeah was your idea just
just just lose a piece that was your
that was your big comeback for that oh
oh oh it was such a good move I just
lose a piece Wow he's befuddled
he's befuddled this Ricardo Alex II Oh
9f5 so you want to just drop that piece
- it's like I'm dropping one of my
Knights which one do you want buddy
which one do you want I'll take the hot
one I'll take the hot one grab it while
it's hooked yeah where are you going
where you go big check coming up [ __ ]
oh he might play f6 Jackie Castle castle
castle
no never Castle
maybe I'll castle long King d8 King d8
alright King d8 it is King d8 it is get
out of there
file by rook e8 oh but that doesn't even
wart cuz then I'm just pinning myself Oh
rook e8 is actually horrible because he
can play Knight f6 and laugh and laugh
and laugh we're not gonna let you laugh
zero zero zero out of the question yeah
that's why I'm just long castle already
backed up anyway now your knight has no
place to go Julian taught me that little
trick that you can just just all his
squares or oh that's your big comeback
a3 that's that's that's the last of it
that's the last of it huh
am i up on plus three look at this
positional maneuver I can't believe it
nobody ever saw it coming
oh now we can just play p4 though again
oh boy oh boy maybe maybe my positional
move wasn't that good
oh my gosh falling apart here I'm
fooling a port oh look at this move
look at this move coming up this move is
gonna be so exciting oh well not really
but only if he plays Knight f1 if he
plays 94 I guess I just take it all
right
I'll get your challenges in we're
playing for 20 more minutes and then
we're gonna call it a day call it a day
and what a day and what a day
just expert over here Ricardo Alex I'll
just expert hey bet ya livestream big
Survivor premiere tonight big so hey
they up 90-minute uh premiere yep Europe
I'm on Team Rob I'm on team alright how
much how much you want to bet on it
you don't do that okay okay that's Mike
it's team Sandra against team rub
I'm on Team Rob two nights and I haven't
watched I watched like the first twenty
seasons of Survivor because I have to a
season and I stopped but now I'm back
because they got team rub against team
Sandra so I'll be traffic team Rob
tonight
that'll be on a CBS 7 o'clock Central
time 7:00 to 8:30 Jeff Probst will be
back they all be back it should be a fun
time no did he get my pawn and now he's
oh my gosh he's threatening to win my
guy huh
that was a bad check by him that was a
bad check
throw on a check
big check coming up
you get the check I get a check are you
all getting a check Chuck yeah and the
chess expert will go down Chuck black is
victorious check out check out my big
victory against the chess expert he
thinks he's so good so good I got just
trust me just trust me timed out let's
play somebody a little bit easier than a
chess expert I'm gonna give this 12:55 a
chance chance of your lifetime 12:55
chance of a lifetime
oh yes there's the national master
the little pony could right there the
little pony could
hey it's all about that hair 78 viewers
that we're gonna have to say goodbye to
them all in 15 minutes huh and I have to
say goodbye
all right oh so just take it yeah shut
me out shut me out they're having a big
party for Caleb then be outside in the
kitchen a new national master and of
course oh my gosh am I gonna lose the
Queen I've did two videos called don't
lose the Queen but luckily I did not
lose the Queen
oh I missed Knight to e5
now with 95 is even better because he
doesn't have rook to d8 no so I rated
just for the perfect time to play Knight
to e5 and this one is in the books
alright alright you had your chance
Pilon let's just give it up and give it
up give it up no get on with the show
we'll get on with the show
run away
take the pawn who are you gonna take the
pawn like that huh
hopping around he's hopping around
he's ahaha
yeah yeah yeah now I could take that
thing I could lay there I guess I'll
just take it
Oh take it and then I'll take that all
right just don't let this Paul and
become a queen buddy don't let it happen
they're like a big check up there oh now
he has to play rook to a3 and then boom
then you can't stop me you just can't
stop me
no please play rook a six you play rook
a six nope you had to play Brook a seven
root K six maybe because after D seven
Brooke d 8 but
let's get rid of this pond and get on
with my show black resigned
why is Victoria so right who invented
the chess clocks Google that's a that's
a that's a thing for Google oh the
powerful pots are the powerful pots
okay uh we're for know I guess the
powerful pot sir all right let's keep
this streak alive the powerful he's so
powerful
see if he allows the color variation
almost there yeah we're about to sixth
of the way no no come on d4 come on d4
all right now
yep just Bishop e3 and we're in the
comer variation transpose there we are
the color variation from the L Chuck's
playing out good move
well it's not good move it's just it's
just avoids all the complications as my
queen is back on d8 castle
there's nothing I can do about that so
hopefully he'll Castle queenside and
we're gonna have some fun all right
let's have some fun let's have some fun
I'm not bluffing I'm not bluffing
everybody
this is exciting this is exciting oh man
I want to give him a check so bad I'll
check you later he's going for it
it's so exciting it's so exciting who's
gonna checkmate who first spoiler alert
its Michael J comer yeah it comes to
checkmate oh man what uh what a doozy I
don't know if there's if this guy's even
got a way out he could throw in h6 check
which would be funny
oh man this is good this is good it's
anybody's game it's anybody's game for
matin to threat
yep that's the that's the thing well mr.
500 I wasn't playing it was Dennis LaRue
so I'm in no I don't want I don't
actually let's just take what the oh but
then are you gonna take are you gonna
really play rook takes check are you
really gonna do that
you know I can't resist taking his first
give them a check now my queen cannot
move okay it's good to know this is
exciting
oh it does 93 just win check let's see
let's see if it really does win check
hang everything let's hang everything oh
my gosh is that it
Oh didn't even know that's why you
always check okay
if you don't know why you check that's
why you check all right that's got to be
the end of the stream Danny all right
all right good night everybody